c'est mignon j'avais fait l'émission
pour la télévision italienne ya très
très longtemps il disait simplement ça
oui je suis catherine deneuve on ne
parlait même pas de la voiture qu'on
était supposé voir boxer loi et c'est
resté cette voie là ça se voit
je pensais que ça allait se limiter à
des questions j'aurais dit à dire un
vrai faux jeton c'est formidable vous en
dit plus que moi
bref oui c'est vrai il ya très longtemps
oui film de ridley scott oui
si jamais vous savez c'est comme les
scènes d'amour dans les films se sent
pas les scènes les plus agréables à
faire les scènes d'intimité physique
comme ça avec quelqu'un d'autre c'est
toujours un peu un peu étrange
l'impression que les acteurs ils sont là
ils s'embrassent ils se cassent comme
c'était mais c'est pas du tout de choses
si simple si facile
faux et c'est pas seulement parce que
c'était emmanuel et que je simba comme
ça où les yeux fermés parce que des gens
avec qui j'ai déjà travaillé que j'aime
beaucoup donc mais je lis vraiment quand
même le scénario
ce serait quoi la plante vous avez une
rose à une rose
ça me plaît beaucoup ça alors ça
j'aimerais bien porter un nom comme ça
tournait en
ans la taille qui porte pour nom ça me
plairait beaucoup à une rose s'est
pacsée pour moi c'est pas vraiment une
plante parce que si vous vouliez a
tellement de tellement de rose qui sont
nos maîtres les joueurs qui pour des
tons différents depuis si longtemps ah
non ça m'aurait bien plu - delta
fougères
bref en vérité c'est vrai il faut parce
qu'au départ on était à l'hôpital donc
après c'est faux la tournée en studio
n'aurait pas pu aller dans un ancien
hôpital à cette période même après le
coup vite donc c'est vrai que moi quand
je les ai vus c'était un choc âme de
voir ce lieu c'est tellement l'hôpital
est vraiment se serait cru à l'hôpital
et pourtant c'était c'était de studio
c'était avec hors
remplacez remplacer c'est beaucoup dire
j'ai arrêté de fumer oui
il faut beaucoup plus assez de ventes
que j'ai décidé de faire pour les
restaurants du coeur les restos du coeur
beaucoup trop encore mais je disais
depuis toujours très longtemps parce que
moi j'adorais les chaussures quand
j'étais même très jeunes décident et des
chaussures j'ai créé c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui me plaisait donc il y
en a beaucoup que j'avais gardé y en a
que j'avais donné évidemment depuis le
tome dont d'année ou jeu pour dédé des
chaussures mais c'est vrai que j'en ai
acheté quand même chaque année donc on
se sert parlant plus de chaussures
chaque année donc oui il y avait
beaucoup trop
faux et je fredonne mais je chante je
chante pas ça du tout d'eau non pas du
tout j'ai beaucoup d'efforts mais je je
connais pas suffisamment depuis je ne
sais même pas les parce que je fredonne
chauffeur donnent souvent dans la vie
mais je sais pas si je suis très
concentré quand je fais du jardinage qui
est très bon pour la tête il est
tellement de choses à faire et à voir
c'est tout bon il y avait aussi à l'aise
bon on va dire vrai ces poésies je sais
que je les rencontrais mais il ya
tellement longtemps oui oui oui j'avais
pas qu'il était là non
ah bon j'aimerais la voir cette photo
c'est drôle
pas grand chose qu'il fallait se parer
voilà porter des gants faire faire une
petite révérence elle touche la main de
tout le monde est là pour de bon ce soir
à tout le monde et oui on doit ce décès
devant la reine oui
bah oui il faut apprendre une petite
révérence dans la mesure où c'est quand
en robes longues dont il faut vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas de problème par rapport
à votre robe
il faut je n'ai pas vu encore
je regarde c'est encore dame se dote
d'un peu loin pour l'instant j'ai
beaucoup d'autres choses en séries que
je regardais qui m'intéresse beaucoup
mais j'attends encore
je viens de reprendre ce qu'elle vient
de repartir cette la succession
voilà entre les deux mon coeur balance
est terrible et cette question elle
préfère truffaut quand même vous
faut j'aime les bouleverse collectionne
les poules non non c'est pas une
collection particulière quand on parlera
plus c'est vrai que j'en ai pas parce
que moi j'aime bien voir l'eau sur le
visage
mais je comprends qu'il soit très très
écoeuré la façon de l'état de paris en
ce moment et je crois qu'il a une très
belle propriété je crois en dehors de
paris mais moi je ne pourrais pas vivre
en dehors de paris
des gens de la ville de bari même avec
ses excès ses folies c'est c'est
énervement mais c'est comme ça
oui j'aime j'adore la campagne je veux
pas être me passer de la campagne que je
ne pourrais pas me passer de paris non
aimer c'est beaucoup dire mais vrai oui
je peux aller au cinéma seul
nom
moi tu détestes les rituels
ses fausses annonces dopent quand ça
c'est vrai ah bon je ne savais pas
pas grand chose donc bon chrétienne
sympa c'est un terme qui me convient je
dire mais bon pas au delà de ça
faux
faux c'est un vrai gâteau de cinéma donc
c'est particulier quand même pour la
recette quand on l'entend je trouve ça
formidable au cinéma d'accord de la
manger le gâteau après
à huy
j'ai par l'outil non emballés ou